diese neue akku technologie soll uns
echte hammer schnelllade akkus bescheren
wie das tanken von benzin
der glas akku wird schon als
revolutionärer nachfolger des
lithium-ionen-akkus gehandelt jetzt hat
sich eine kanadische firma die lizenzen
an der technologie gesichert kommen also
schon bald akkus auf den markt mit denen
wir unsere smartphones und sogar
elektroautos in wenigen minuten aufladen
können klicks um science-fiction hier
gibt's täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst er nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen john boehner
hat letztes jahr im stattlichen alter
von 97 jahren den nobelpreis für chemie
für die entwicklung der lithium ionen
batterie erhalten doch dass er der
älteste nobelpreisträger ist den es je
gegeben hat hält ihn noch lange nicht
davon ab weiter zu forschen gerade
arbeitet er am nachfolger der lithium
ionen batterie an einer echten super
batterie die nicht nur den einsatz von
elektroautos revolutionieren könnte das
geheimnis der technologie ist das glas
oder keramik anstelle von lithium
polymeren eingesetzt wird damit gehört
es zu den sogenannten festkörper akkus
auf die gerade ein regelrechter run
herrscht autohersteller auf der ganzen
welt investieren denn solche akku
technologien um die zukunft ihrer autos
zu sichern auch das neue glas akku
verspricht eine regelrechte revolution
für unsere stromspeicher in
herkömmlichen akkus bestehen die
elektrolyte also das material zwischen
kathode und anode meist aus
flüssigkeiten was sie leichter
entflammbar und anfällig bei extrem
heißen oder kaltem wetter macht beim
glas akku wird stattdessen ein gemisch
aus glas und alkali metallen wie auch
lithium eines ist als elektrolyt
eingesetzt dadurch soll er eine enorme
kapazität haben super schnell aufladen
und nicht nur unempfindlich gegenüber
extremen temperaturen seinen sondern
auch noch schwer entflammbar
schon 2016 wurde ein erster
forschungsbericht zum glas akku
veröffentlichte nur wenige wochen später
wo die die technologie öffentlich
präsentiert werden damals server
berichtet die universität von texas in
austin an der guten lauf arbeitet
meldete die patente für die technologie
an und jetzt scheint es ernst zu werden
denn diese patente werden nun an hydro
québec übergeben ein kanadisches
energieversorgungsunternehmen das als
führend in der entwicklung von
batterietechnologien gilt das
unternehmen betreibt ein eigenes
forschungszentrum das center of
excellence in transportation
electrification and energy storage das
soll den glas ab jetzt zur
markteinführung weiter entwickeln hydro
québec hat schon verschiedene
batterietechnologien kommerzialisiert
und vergibt dafür in der regel lizenzen
an andere unternehmen auch eine
technologie für einen anderen feststoff
akku hat das unternehmen schon in seinem
portfolio
damit baut das unternehmen blues
solutions energiespeicher die zb in
bussen eingesetzt werden autobusse mit
elektroantrieb sind die perfekten
testfahrzeuge für solche technologien
weil ihr fahrprofil vorhersehbar ist und
sie großzügig platz bieten hydro québec
arbeitet übrigens auch mit mercedes benz
zusammen an neuen batterietechnologien
doch was bedeutet die übertragung der
lizenzen jetzt für die markteinführung
des glas akkus wie weit ist die super
batterie schon und wann kann sie
tatsächlich eingesetzt werden bisher
gibt es noch keinen funktionierenden
prototypen der glas batterie die anode
also der pluspol und das elektrolyt sind
bereits fertig entwickelt aber es stehen
noch arbeiten an der kathode den
minuspol aus konkret bedeutet das dass
in den nächsten zwei jahren noch weitere
forschung aussteht um das konzept zu
überprüfen und den materialeinsatz
abzuwägen
danach könnte es dann endlich soweit
sein dass die glas batterien in unseren
geräten und autos landen good enough der
schon die lithium-ionen-batterie mit
erfunden hat die heute in jedem handy
oder elektro auto steckt will sich bis
dahin wohl nicht zur ruhe setzen und
sagt zitat ich will das problem noch
lösen bevor ich alles hinschmeißen
sein alter sieht dann da übrigens als
vorteil zitat man macht sich keine
sorgen mehr seinen job zu verlieren mit
dieser gelassenheit des
nobelpreisträgers lässt es sich doch gut
aushalten bis es dann 2022 so weit ist
dass wir unsere geräte in minuten statt
in stunden wieder aufladen
bahnbrechende technologien bringt
umweltfreundliche batterie anklicken
anschauen und klicks und nature
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran